they were the subjects of the so-called
tinker experiment
they call it eugenics social engineering
over decades
that separated families and ruined lives
i was born in an experiment
and had no say anymore
in a clearing in a pursue forest is the
gypsy traveller community
seamus mcphee was born into 50 years ago
then it was one location of many for the
tinker experiment
primitive hearts seen here after they
were occupied
built to encourage gypsy travelers away
from a nomadic existence
and towards settle society but all
executed
with sinister intent according to
shameless
to demolish and eradicate gypsy culture
and to affect a form of cultural
genocide
and it was part of a punitive series of
measures
you know a drive against offseason
purges against gypsy travelers
with a view to making them conform
the tinker experiment led to some
families being broken up
if a family outgrew the accommodation it
was given
children could be taken into care the
damage is done
it won't be repaired teresa was one of
those children
even before she and her twin brother
were born they were earmarked for
removal from the family home
her brother died in middle age an
alcoholic
teresa blames a lifelong trauma rooted
in his childhood experience
it had a terrible impact on his life
he's the one that suffered the most
because he couldn't cope with it
there were several thousand people
involved in the so-called tinker
experiments
which lasted over many years in recent
years
those involved have sought a formal
apology from the scottish government
which hasn't been forthcoming a
spokesperson said
we accept the lives of many gypsy
travelers have been blighted by
historical policies and practices
of councils and charities and we
absolutely recognize the devastating
and lasting impact this had we must now
focus on working together
to deliver the actions to address the
inequality and injustice
that this community continues to face
it's a government's stated intention to
get things right
if not the apology sought for an
experiment gone wrong
james matthews sky news in perthshire